thank you for bidding on me in the
auction i am so flattered that somebody
your age would be a fan of my work i
don't know who the hell you are
my ex really wanted to meet you so he
bit how much 22.
2200 that's fantastic 22
it started at 20 and then it went up in
50 cent increments
i'm a comedy writer all right guys very
funny stuff i also
write for broadway and movies why is
your face suddenly bigger than it was
before oh my god are you allergic to
seafood
oh my god she doesn't have insurance and
she really shouldn't be leaving here by
herself your daughter is going to be
fine
my why did you tell the doctor that i
was your father i was a little loopy by
then
are you doing anything right now no one
have some laughs come on queen smile
girl smile
marilyn monroe from the seven year rich
i beat you too if i had hot subway air
blowing up my ass
doctor thanks for seeing me so late
how's the writing going it's all of
these young kids
in the tradition of george carlin and
richard pryor somebody's got to talk to
roger about his inflections
come on sub peanuts what is that a very
small peanut
are you doing what we talked about i try
not to vary my routine you have
medicines to help you i was backed up
for like eight days and you can always
give yourself an enema
i'm saving that for my birthday
who are they that's my family if they're
your family why do you have their names
written down
charlie you can't be alone anymore if
you ever need my help i'm here
i'm writing something and i have to
finish before my words run out
i'll take care of them may ask what your
relationship is i don't know i don't
know
let's travel just the hottest i know
do you live here i'm his friend but your
dad needs you right now
i mean this young woman is full of
surprises this is no time for jokes
it's the perfect time for jokes you
funny old man
everybody needs somebody sometimes
[Music]
i want to have fun i want to laugh i
want to not be scared
and i want to write the book and i want
to do all of that with you
hell yeah everybody needs somebody
sometime
whoa huh i didn't want for this to
happen that this it didn't happen
your little frail body would not be able
to handle all these groceries i'll break
your back then you die
can't have it
[Music]